Joanna says,
some researchers see shame as something
that is very disruptive.
The consensus seems to be that it is an
emotion that is always disruptive.
Do you agree with this?
No,
that's absolutely ridiculous.
And only modern psychologists and
probably social psychologists would be
foolish enough to even dare deposit
sense something so absolutely observed.
Psychopathy and shamelessness are the
same thing.
So shame isn't shame.
No emotion is always destructive.
Any emotion taken to an extreme can be
disruptive,
just like any value taken to an extreme,
you know,
made into one thing can be destructive.
So,
um,
joy can be destructive.
I mean,
people who are manic are in some sense
possessed by a radical excess of
positive emotion and they,
they get incredibly impulsive and so,
and it's terribly destructive.
I mean,
there's almost no form of insanity
that's more destructive than mania.
People will go out and spend all their
money,
all their family's money and well and
engage in all sorts of hyper optimistic
interactions with the world.
It will result in their complete rude.
So,
you know,
people think of happiness as an
untrammeled positive.
Well,
if you think of happiness as positive
emotion,
which is partly true because it's also
the absence of negative emotion.
If you think of happiness as only a
good,
then you have no idea about the
pathologies of positive emotion and
their manifold and shame.
It's like if you do something stupid and
destructive to yourself or to yourself
and the broader social community,
you should feel shame and you should pay
attention to it and you should learn
from it,
and if you're not capable of doing that,
that then people should stay the hell
away from you because you're shameless,
and of course for most of western
history,
and I don't know enough about other
forms of history to also make the same
comment to call someone.
Shameless was,
it was.
It was a tremendous insult.
It meant that they didn't have enough
sense to be appalled by their own
pathology and that's.
That's just not a good thing at all.